has there ever been a moment where you
were like
crap your pants scared seeing something
uh geiger counter being put into a drug
tunnel
yeah what was up with that and it went
off like crazy or what no but just the
fact that they were testing the geiger
counter on on drug tunnels was weird you
know i was like uh
like i knew what a geiger counter was
and i was like wait
like was this some jack bauer
going on smuggling
who was putting the geiger counter in
there we just heard it so usually when
you would find something like that you
would get somebody on the u.s side
coming down into it to verify where it
you know verified the the exit point or
sometimes on the mexican side would go
down into it and like hey we found
something we're going to walk
and then we're going to ping you to see
where it leads you know the military
would usually do that
uh but experiencing some of that and
actually seeing somebody we heard the
guy here counter was like
should we
not be here i was like a weird unknown
thing i mean i guess the worry by the us
government somebody might kind of put a
nuke into the country like that i don't
know like experienced that once and that
was kind of like like creepy how is it
that there are all these tunnels that
they know about and they're still there
that they haven't like buried them like
who knows about them well you just said
they were like 80 or some that we know
about
people talk about somewhere along the
lines of 50 to 60 active tunnels on the
border and if they know i mean they know
they're somewhere they just don't know
how to find them or they know how to
find them but they won't do anything to
find them maybe
what if we did a moat and filled it with
alligators okay i read once in the news
that donald trump suggested that
alligator mode yeah i think it's it's
gonna be expensive feeding all those
allergies alligators no
also mexicans have a tendency to make
stuff out of alligators
hunting grounds you can't do that there
was there was a story where they claimed
that trump suggested building an
alligator moat yeah it's that's insane
was that that no was that the babylon
bee or is that right no it's really yeah
they're trying to wipe stuff up they
just make stuff up yeah i mean
trump could nudge not just a joke and be
like you know we needed some alligators
in the mode right i'm just
um
it's it's i mean it's a complicated
issue um
there's no way you can make that the
from cedar shining see a border wall
yeah i mean
some of some of the new parts of the
board have already more wall have
already fallen over you know this is the
funny thing about when trump was like
when he wanted concrete the the border
patrol agents were like we need to see
on the other side yeah we need to be
able to see what's coming yeah and he
was like oh okay and so then they
experimented with like half bollard
fencing half concrete and they were like
you still can't see a lot of it and then
it doesn't make sense and so they were
like just do a big multi-layered fence
with patrols and that seems to work and
target key areas and that seems to work
there's there's a lot of areas that's
like really hard to pass anyway right
like mountain rocks and water yeah and
also i mean
what you want if you're a smuggler is to
jump over a fence and have a population
where you can blend into immediately
that's what you want
another reason why you wouldn't have a
concrete border wall or just a flat
steel fence like that is because wind
knocks it over that's the simple right
reason why that's just not feasible
but even with these new iron slats that
they made i mean there's a bunch of
cartel videos and just smuggling videos
of them
actually making their own fake fence and
putting it over the real one and putting
a hinge to open it up
or or small concealed doors where they
just peer through so they'll cut it and
then replace it with a door the door the
door wow wow man
jump over it
rope ladders
uh you name it they they do it it's it's
it's interesting to see then again they
say it's to slow people down
we we were talking before about you're
doing trainings on occult stuff yeah so
there's actually a position in which
they're like you need to explain to
these agents
occult ideology or like symbolism or
there's a law enforcement every now and
then reaches out i mean agencies local
state and federal sometimes reach out
with questions and and like do a lot of
consultation
related to them finding a safe house
somewhere and
i don't know like the
i can talk about some of these but you
know somewhere on the east coast they
found this house with a bunch of
cartel stuff in it
um
guns plate armor
with a certain type of setup and a giant
santa muerte statue
uh santa marta's uh basically uh
it's a
in mexico they they venerate death uh as
a as a deity so
a giant reaper statue in a place and it
had certain colors the candles were a
certain way there was a plate with
certain offerings
and uh you know five federal agents that
are caucasian from
you know that have no idea what they're
looking at are now asking me like what
does this mean
and i was exposed to a lot of this stuff
growing up in mexico and also you know
being part of some of that growing and
going through my training and then
arresting people that are part of the
cult and also just going doing my
research out there
um so they asked questions like what do
these candles mean
or what does it mean if it's this color
or the the the statue was a black statue
it wasn't sometimes you find them in
rainbow colors or red or yellow rainbow
death rainbow death basically if you
want to cover all your your bases
lgbt death infested well it's not for
real well i mean it's uh
if you have money problems love problems
if you want to kill somebody and you
don't want to get killed back
and you want to have
luck in a future endeavor you go for a
rainbow statue because it covers all
your bases yeah really yeah but if you
want to you know if you're in the
profession of death dealing in which
some of these people are basically
consider themselves agents of death
you have a black statue because she
gives you the authority to kill other
people and she you're under her
protection so
small insights like that is what i
provide to some law enforcement
professionals out there that are finding
some of these things i don't know what
they mean yeah do you think that they're
using them just to scare other people or
that they really believe i mean it's
speculation it's a belief it's a belief
and it's not just the cartels i mean
it's in the i mean i was exposed to some
of the police forces hazing hazing
rituals and it's like some of the people
that i used to work with were part of
the cult as well um it's like it's like
spread out
uh
it's it's a desperate place it's one of
the most catholic countries in the world
and some of these things just thrive in
places like that
they have santa muerte which is a death
deity
they have malverde which is like a
mexican robin hood the dude that
used to rob the rich and would give the
money to the poor
he was hanged and they didn't allow him
to bury his body
but where his body eventually brought it
away and landed they put a bunch of
rocks there and they started venerating
him as a saint and you know there's a
there's a there's a shrine to him in
sinawa
you go there and you see pictures of
people with their you know new raptors
and the states you know
like thank you for letting me cross and
i just came back to repay you you what
you did for me or somebody with a gold
ac somewhere you know like this you know
wow so people it's a belief system so a
lot of this is actually being
brought with people stateside so there's
like a santa marta church in l.a
there's a roadside every now and then
you find like i find like roadside
graffiti and or shrines of tim alberta
or like some of these things are like
it's here again now
does that just mean saint death santa
muerte yeah so the holy death holy death
santa was the saint of death basically
have you ever encountered some of these
people like in your deals with security
yeah do they come off as like weird when
you're encountering them i mean they
they are
realistically they're as weird as the
catholic
because it's it's basically uh
it's a concealed it's a it's concealed
within catholicism
but it's basically a cult or a
veneration of an aztec death deity
that's what it is it's a fusion it is
this last surviving lineage of any sort
of
uh mexica or aztec death worship
in mexico so so you're bringing in the
sainthood of catholicism and you're the
same so so catholicism is basically the
cloak that it has concealed itself into
all day right so
back in the day it wasn't a public thing
so you would see a virgin mary statue
and behind her there was a skeleton
painted
so that's how they would hide their
veneration right and even to this day um
the la virgen de guadalupe the virgin
the the brown version that they
venerated in mexico
there's an eagle
feathered cherub underneath her
pushing her up interesting and a cherub
doesn't have eagle wings
uh specifically black tipped eagle wings
that is the aztec war god
and the athletic morgon was giving birth
to by cuatrico
which later on turned into holy death
so in a lot of ways it's always been
kind of concealed in plain view for
people but now it's adopted itself into
being venerated by marginalized
communities criminal groups police
officers the military you know that is
who venerates it
and its elements have crossed the border
and every now and then the law
enforcement finds them up here and like
what the hell are we looking at you know
and um you know some of the ritualized
killings they did they do it for for
video purposes that they spread on
social media and stuff like that see
that that's a bit different from like
christians you know
i don't i don't think we get a lot of
that yeah you get some weird stuff for
sure but alex jones was on before and
talking about like these these kind of
blood rituals that they would do the
aztecs and stuff and i looked into it
and it's called bloodletting it's an
ancient very well-known bloodletting is
just like kind of a headache so you
drain blood or something similar yeah
and it's like he was like you put glass
through your genitals that's all
bloodletting that's ancient so
i went through a bunch of weird hazing
rituals coming up through training and a
lot of them were done by people so a lot
of the training that i went through
first was done by
gotham members
gotham members are the people that later
on turn into the zetas it's basically a
a mexican army sf group that
said well these guys pay more so they
just left the person they just left the
barracks and became bodyguards to one of
the biggest cartel heads in back then
a lot of these people a lot of these
guys were the ones that were in charge
of our training like coming up so they
were pretty brutal in some of the
training and they also introduced a few
weird occult elements into some of the
training we got right interesting uh so
uh there was a they would cut you
to see if you would flinch right so like
uh
now that they cut me with a knife right
there
and there was always you know some sort
of pain or just suffering of some sort
to see if you were strong enough and
there was always bleeding happening it
was a weird thing so you were under were
you undercover no this is this is this
is from this government training to get
you into go to work on on some of these
things uh and again it's a the occultist
elements in that are everywhere like
they're infused into the culture you see
them within the military you see that
with the criminal groups you know um i
remember the first time we went to a
house and we found this giant
actual human skull
statue
in the bottom of it it had a bowl and it
had the picture of the guy that ran us
or the guy one of our bosses was
in the bowl and looked at us like took a
picture of it and sent it back
and he was like burning the house
you ever experienced anything in like
pursuit of or investigation of you know
some occult stuff that gave you pause or
made you question
i mean is stuff real i think uh
things have a power that we give them
right things have a power the power that
we give them to uh so
specifically i think uh
there was there was this lady who was a
she was pretty famous i can't i can't
say her name but she was pretty famous
for being like the head witch of of
cartel people oh wow
and
everybody feared her everybody feared
her she was he had the
maldives power and she will she could
curse you by your site and stuff like
that
um when i wanted to learn more about
this type of stuff for my own research
and just to know about it to kind of
gather some of this information so then
kind of transfer the people that might
need it later on in life
um i helped out two of her sons that
were in a stolen vehicle thing right so
i helped him out and i told him i just
need an intro to your mom so i can you
know talk about some of these things
sure
i went to her place where she would do
her you know her work
she's arrived in a mercedes in the back
you know
change that chains out of her you know
good clothes and put on a weird you know
you know witch costume i guess
lady comes in my husband is cursed and
she works for the cartels and he's
cursed and i need my work done on him
okay um i don't know the name of the
demon that is placed on your husband so
i can't take this job slides over the
five hundred dollars she just put on the
table it's like wow this is an honest
witch
yeah wow
but if things start happening at your
husband's house at three in the morning
i think i might know the name so come
back
as soon as she leaves two kids walk in
with a bag full of cats
and they get tasked with going and
following this lady and going to her
house and dumping these cats in her
backyard
okay she comes back with five thousand
dollars
to get rid of this curse whatever this
is
um
i mean
black magic at its core is just a form
of weaponized psychology i think so this
is not something that made you believe
something made you this is something to
believe this is something that made me
respect the ability of manipulation that
some human beings have and reanalyze
everything i thought was real that's
classic con game material i knew a guy
once and he he he worked with a guy
and uh
when i started talking to him he told me
the story about how he lent his friend
five grand and i was like what why he
said no it's fine he's good for it he's
paid me back before and i'm like dude
what happened and he's like yeah he has
to borrow 500 bucks you know a couple
weeks ago and said i'll pay you back on
payday and i lent him the money and then
sure enough payday comes around he paid
me back no problem and then you know he
needed to uh to help out
you know he was trying to get married
but his family didn't approve of his
wife so he needed you know to go fly
back home to china where he could then
you know sort things out his family and
he he's got a job here i was like bro
you just got kant he stole all your
money he's never coming back
and that's that's what they do
you give me 500 bucks i wait a week hand
it right back to you i never spent it
that way in a week i can be like hey can
you lend me f you know five grand you're
like you know i'll pay you back i paid
you back last time that's the trick so
when she's like no no i can't take your
money because i have to know if the
demon is real
and then they go nuts on you and then
you're like she was right
yeah something happened it's it's a
it's a it's like i call it i nicknamed
mexico the upside down you know
because it's a different place people
don't realize how different it is
we would get numbers attached to us as
like a call sign right or a nickname my
nickname was skeletor you know they call
me skeletor it's pretty skinny when i
first got a shirt you got like a little
skeleton yeah there we go
um
and i had a number given to me at 2-4
and i had an upside-down 4 on my number
and i didn't realize it was a joke
the joke was my first job working was to
cut people down from a bridge that were
hung by cartels that was one of my first
jobs
and talking about some hair raising
experiences
this was pretty subtle
but it was
it made me realize a few things about
mexico
um
we got to this place and they had uh
two or three
well two and what was remaining of
another one hanging from a bridge
uh
we got there and i got i remember going
there and i got like hey bring the
breaching kit and which is a pair of
bolt cutters and a thing to knock down
the doors and i was like yeah we're
going to hit a house and they're on the
nose sign we're going to go somewhere
else oh and i got handed the bowl
cutters and i didn't know what was going
to do when i got there and i was like oh
we're going to you know you're the one
in charge cutting them down
i i go over they put a flat back thing
on the bottom and we just cut somebody
down
and i was like that's a that's a [ __ ]
this is horrible
this is horrible
older guy they're smoking a guy with
jaramillo is his name
older guy smoking says
that's kind
they're being kind it's like how is this
kind
i mean at least their his family is
going to have a body to cry over and
bury
the body is a gift
and i was like brutal this is this is
this is kindness here that's why i've
heard crazy stories about what they do
to people they're like flaying them
alive playing along with
explosives putting on people
dragging them through a city
horrible i mean the videos are out there
and some of these i mean some of the
afters of these some things like um
there was a guy posolero was a stool
maker in tijuana as uh he never killed
anybody but he said that he learned from
israeli specialists how to get rid of
bodies and he got rid of bodies at an
industrial level whoa with caustic soda
oh wow and
uh like
one of my guys ran through a field once
and got off his foot inside of one of
the pits where he would dump things and
he got he had to go to the hospital for
chemical stuff and also
the hole exposed the smell
which is to this day i can you know i
can't go to korean barbecue places
because it just freaks me out
people people in the united states do
not realize how good they have it they
they don't they don't they don't not
only realize how good they have it up
here they don't realize how some of this
is also starting to pop up up here yeah
and also and also how some of this stuff
affects some of the stuff that happens
on their effects up here directly
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you